Thomas Trudel 16 ans qui fréquentait
l'école secondaire Joseph François
Perrot dans le quartier Saint-Michel a
été froidement abattu en début de soirée
tout près de son école le 14 novembre
dernier mais c'est justement pour éviter
ce genre de drame que la Ville de
Montréal et son service de police
annonce la création d'une nouvelle
équipe d'intervention auprès des jeunes
d'écoles secondaires notamment donc
cette équipe siminaire là est composé de
criminologues d'un expert en médias
sociaux d'un expert aussi en
développement de programme et de 4
policiers quand on peut rattraper un
jeune qui fait des petits délits mais ça
évite beaucoup de problèmes dans le
futur ça c'est démontré dans toutes les
aspects de la prévention ça c'est un des
objectifs et aussi devenir un appui aux
parents les médias sociaux sont un des
moyens de communication préféré des
jeunes mais ils peuvent être aussi un
moyen de proférer des menaces par
exemple cette équipe-là va pouvoir nous
permettre d'ajouter par exemple au
niveau de la cybercriminalité c'est un
enjeu pour lequel on n'a pas toujours
dans les écoles l'expertise requise
cette équipe-là va nous apporter ce
soutien supplémentaire-là pour agir à
plusieurs niveaux quand on parle de
violence dans les écoles et de violence
en général selon ce spécialiste en
sécurité publique et bien on parle de
problème qui ne peut pas être réduit
seulement par les forces de l'ordre et
je pense que au milieu encore une fois
sur la police pour régler un problème
social cette nouvelle équipe école sera
mise en place au cours des prochaines
semaines maintenant la Ville de Montréal
est sans doute la population générale
espère qu'elle viendra freiner et
surtout prévenir la violence dans la
ville ici Jacques bissonner Radio-Canada
Montréal